my friend says hey my sister brought
back all these free posters you want
some right now why would the Soviet
Union give away free propaganda posters
too naive stupid you know
Westerners so I remember an imagined
life choosing one of Lenin and thinking
well that sort of looks okay and I put
it up I was living off-campus in my room
my mom and dad came to visit and my
father looked at it and he looked at me
and he said Eric could I speak with you
for a minute
and it suddenly dawned on me my father
said I want to ask you a favor would you
take that down and it was as if the
scales fell from my eyes and I realized
what what has happened to me I mean
they're 100 other examples but those are
the two moments that I remember suddenly
coming to myself and thinking how is it
possible that I thought it was okay to
do that when my father raised me to
despise communism you know the way souls
and eason and Buckley despised communism
[Music]
I'm Dave Rubin and this is the Rubin
report don't forget guys to subscribe to
our YouTube channel and click that pesky
notification bell and joining me today
is a New York Times bestselling author
the host of the Eric Metaxas radio show
and a senior fellow at King's College in
New York Eric Metaxas welcome to the
Rubin report thank you so much I'm also
now a senior fellow at the Falkirk
Center at Liberty University
ever-so-slightly conservative folks down
there yeah can you be a senior fellow at
two different places is that is that
possible is that not a gun point of
interest if they don't listen to this
then the answer is yes yeah I hate to
tell you but I do have a lot of fans at
Liberty University I spoke there and
they be watching this then I tell you
know I love I love them and I love
Charley Kirk and I'm I've just just done
that just become a senior fellow with
Falkirk so it's uh it's a wonderful
thing well listen man I'm very happy to
have you here because I'm gonna do a Mia
culpa right up front I was on my book
tour as you
no for about a month just sitting in
this chair being interviewed by I
probably did hundreds of interviews and
you were one of the people that
interviewed me and I did not know who
you were before you interviewed me I'm
just saying it I have now done a
tremendous amount of research you've
written four billion books I found you
to be one of the most interesting
insightful curious wordsmith
interviewers of all the people that I
talk to you and I wanted to return the
favor so that's just me getting it out
of the way here first of all that is so
nice of you
and you didn't need to do that that's
like people say you know I had a really
really hateful thought toward you seven
years ago and I wanted to confess it and
you think I wish you hadn't told me that
why did you have to do that no I
wouldn't expect you to be aware of me
Dave but you're very kind to say that I
and then the listen here's the point
you're aware of me now I'm aware of you
we're all good
we're also addressed the same and our
hair sort a similar ish so we're in good
company alright but but you're you're a
really established guy you've done a ton
of great things and written several
great books so for anyone in my audience
that does not know who Eric Metaxas is I
just read through your whole bio and all
sorts of interesting stuff you were you
were born in New York City it seems like
no one's actually born in New York City
when I listen but very few has had to be
I had to be my mom came from Germany on
a boat in the mid 50s my dad came from
Greece on a boat they met in an English
class here in New York City to learn how
to speak English and when a Greek man is
involved in having a family that kid has
to be born legally in Astoria New York
so that's why I was born Astoria that's
where I started life Jackson Heights
Queens but I spent most my life in
Danbury Connecticut correct me if I'm
wrong you have to be born into a bed of
feta cheese is that you know something
true
very few people know that very few
people know that because yeah but still
I understand what you're saying
nonetheless okay before we get to your
books and I want to talk about your
feelings on on Trump and the culture
wars and we'll do some economics and all
sorts of stuff tell me a little bit
about what got you into this
talking world of raid
vo and writing and all of that stuff
what is the ethos of Eric Metaxas I've
got to give you the the super quick
version cuz otherwise we'll be here for
the full hour talking about it basically
you know I am the son of immigrants my
parents still have accents and they
raised me like most immigrants to this
country in the 50s and any time before
the 60s they raised me to love America
because they knew how wonderful it was
having come from places you know my
mother escaped East Germany when she was
seventeen years old because of the
propaganda coming to her in high school
my father saw the civil war with the
Communists in Greece in the early 50s so
they came here they love America they
taught me to love America and they
raised me with you know basic homespun
middle American values you know we went
to church every Sunday but we weren't
born again or evangelicals if you're
Greek I always say if you're born Greek
if your parents are Greek in German you
will be raised Greek okay there's no
option that you're gonna be raised any
other way except full Greek so we went
to church and stuff and when I went to
Yale the American Dream right my parents
then get to go to college I get to go to
Yale University well of course what
happens young Eric drinks the wolf
kool-aid of the early 80s and my
worldview you know I would have
considered myself roughly speaking
conservative and Christian before I know
it I taught oh no no no that's kind of
bigoted and small-minded and parochial
so by the time I graduated I was totally
lost I was I was not exactly an activist
woke person but the the political
correctness bug hit some of those top
institutions early and I was one of
those just confused people who had a
vaguely you know anti-american sense of
things I really betrayed all the things
that my parents had had taught me and so
I was I was very confused now the one
thing that happened when I was in
college is that I knew that I wanted to
be a writer I originally thought I want
to go to politics but I started reading
you know the great works of the Western
Canon and it's one of these things it's
like a gene I immediately
he said this is what I want to do I want
to write I love words I love ideas but I
didn't know what I wanted to write
exactly so I I won some awards at Yale
for my fiction writing I was the editor
of the humor magazine there I knew I had
a career in writing but it really wasn't
until I graduated that I realized how
lost I was because now you know you
don't have the guardrails of academia to
keep you you know this is what I'm doing
today this is what I'm doing today
suddenly I'm lost I want to be a writer
but I don't have a worldview other than
I know you know sort of how I'm supposed
to think and I went through some really
tough tough years where I was just I was
just lost I wasn't some like bold sinner
I was just totally lost what's the
meaning of life can you know whether
life has a meaning is there a God what
you know I really I always say that you
know if you get a good job you won't
have time to think about that stuff and
I think that's the ethos of a place like
Yale of all these institutions their
idea is we we ceased about a hundred
years ago answering the big questions
what's the meaning of life is there a
god what's the meaning of your life
where do you go when you die where do we
come from we don't go there they don't
go there so what they sort of tell you
is like study really hard to get a great
job and you'll be able to distract
yourself for a few decades and then
it'll all be over so just do whatever
you do don't think about the big
questions well I was an English major I
want to be a writer guess what happened
I didn't get a good job I had several
years to think about the big questions
and it got so bad that I ended up moving
back in with my parents if your parents
are European immigrants working-class
European immigrants who sent you to Yale
you do not want to move back in with
them trust me on this one it was it was
pure hell and in the midst of that hell
I did the only thing that you could do
which is I got a job as a proofreader at
Union Carbide corporation in Danbury
Connecticut I'm living with my parents
and I'm going to a chemical conglomerate
to do like it was pure hell and in the
midst of that hell I met a guy who was
pretty serious Christian and he begins
sharing his faith with me and I had the
standard you know Yale response like
don't
get new clothes with that weird stuff
but I was in enough pain that I was
listening a little bit and this kind of
cat-and-mouse game went on for about a
year and I would say roughly a year into
it the cut to the chase
I had a very dramatic conversion dream
it was one of those things like it's out
of a book it was a miracle nothing else
could have sufficed to drag me you know
across the broomstick into another
universe basically because I thought all
those people are insane so I had this
miraculous conversion and I've spent the
last 30 years sort of trying to process
this reading books and stuff but it was
because of that that I very quickly
became a conservative I think it was you
know the pro-life issue and a few other
issues that I just thought wow I
remember also I was watching you know
the the Bork hearings on TV I mean
imagine I thought holy cow like the the
guys that I would have voted for are
really evil they're really bad so I had
this kind of experience
so ever since then I've known I wanted
to be in the culture I knew I wanted to
be a writer I wasn't sure what I want to
write but I always had a dream of doing
a mainstream TV talk show kind of like
Dick Cavett who's become a friend
because I think we need to have those
kinds of conversations and wouldn't it
be nice if the host had more traditional
more conservative more faith friendly
views than most of the people do so
that's the long answer would you prefer
the short answer I can give it to you
later it's a little late for that by
taxes but to prove to you I'm a good
interviewer now what you did there as
the guest in this case was give me a
hundred offshoots
there's a hundred outlets to go to right
now and I want to get back to I want to
get back to a lot of the things you talk
about there from the from sort of
secularism on steroids which is sort of
what you're describing yell as to to the
big questions they were forcing you to
avoid and a whole a whole slew of other
things but let's back up a little bit
further you described sort of the
immigrant family and you went into
college somewhat conservative do you
remember the moments where that started
breaking up yeah yeah where the ideas
were really infecting you yeah can you
I've actually I'll never forget it and I
and I in fact I have just finished
writing like the memoir of my life that
takes me up to my twenty-fifth birthday
in this dramatic conversion dream and in
there I write about these two things
that basically first of all I was
hanging out with a lot of different
people but the general Emilia was
secular humanist liberal no question
about it
and I was you know by being raised the
way I was I kind of bumped into this
like what's this I didn't know that oh
you can't say oriental you have to say
Asian you can't say like suddenly I was
getting all of these things that oh you
can't do that you can't do this and I
was like oh so I was raised by people
who didn't know this stuff but now MIT
Yale where everybody knows everything
these are the future leaders and and I'm
just gonna go along with them so you're
picking this stuff up but I remember two
instances this is classic I remember I
was we had a vote you could this is
nothing has changed in all these years
we were having a vote whether our class
funds should divest from corporations
that were involved in South Africa right
because it was right before a part that
I broke up and everything like that and
and what I find interesting is that
there was only one way to vote in other
words it wasn't like let's actually
think about this it was kind of the woke
thing like are you gonna say how Hitler
or not you're gonna take a knee or not
we're not giving you choices you know
what you need to do are you gonna do it
here's your opportunity to do it and to
show solidarity so everybody voted the
right way except a friend of mine who
oddly enough is a Democrat but he was an
economics major and he said no I don't
actually think it's gonna help the
people of South Africa we do there so he
voted okay a different way but here's
the key the next day in the dining hall
a very dear friend of mine comes up to
me who was involved in this voting
process and he says hey your buddy Chris
you know he he voted no and I'll never
forget it's as if my whole upbringing
you know came to me and I thought this
is America
you mean you looked at his vote and you
have you dare to tell me that he voted
the wrong way as though it wasn't an
actual
and that's what they do in Red China
like I remember being chilled just being
horrified not too long after that I had
an experience where a friend of mine
sister and I imagine this is still
Reagan so a friend of mine sister went
to the Soviet Union this is like all the
you know the woke Manhattan elites send
their kids to whatever schools and
there's a semester in Moscow to study
economics and she brought back a ton of
propaganda posters so my friend says hey
my sister brought back all these free
posters you want some right now why
would the Soviet Union give away free
propaganda posters too naive stupid you
know
Westerners so I remember an imagined
life choosing one of Lenin and thinking
well that sort of looks okay and I put
it up I was living off-campus in my room
my mom and dad came to visit and my
father looked at it and he looked at me
and he said Eric could I speak with you
for a minute
and it suddenly dawned on me my father
said I want to ask you a favor would you
take that down and it was as if the
scales fell from my eyes and I realized
what what has happened to me I mean
there are hundred other examples but
those are the two moments that I
remember suddenly coming to myself and
thinking how is it possible that I
thought it was okay to do that when my
father raised me to despise communism
you know the way souls and eason and
Buckley despised communism so what's
interesting about this to me there's a
couple things but particularly is that
if you listen to sort of mainstream
media now this this idea of the woke
college thing people think it's it's a
it's an idea of the last five years or
something like that or it's yeah it's
just this last millennial generation
that's going through it what what years
were you in college I was I was there I
graduated in 84 but it was in full swing
it was in full swing in the early 80s
and look let's be honest this stuff
started at least in 1968 I mean it's
only a matter of the trickle-down effect
when did it get to the mainstream and
the fact of the matter is that Yale and
places like that are they're the worst
offenders of this kind of stuff I if I
ever had money I wouldn't give them
money they are the absolute worst
offenders they have been leading
the charge with this kind of stuff so I
saw this you know maybe earlier than a
lot of other people did but it was it
was an absolute full force so I feel
like we got to talk about that dream a
little bit because you told me you had a
dream and it changed your life but we
need to know some details on this thing
yeah well I always tell people to go to
my website to watch the video of the
dream because it's very hard takes I
will try because I like you
I will try very hard to be much of life
I wasn't the first question it's tricky
stuff I'll tell you why and this is I
wrote a whole book on miracles and
sometimes what makes a miracle dramatic
is the context right in other words if
God is speaking to someone it may make
sense to that person because they bring
a whole bunch of context to that
situation and it wouldn't mean anything
to anyone else in my case if you had you
know put a gun to my head at age 24 and
said who are you you know you know like
in a dream or in a fairy tale in your
core who are you I would have you know I
don't think I could have come up with it
but but the most basic elements if they
were let's say three of who who I was at
that point where the Greek immigrant
upbringing was at the at the center of
my life there's no question and the
second thing was that for all of my you
know teen years or childhood or whatever
I I was fishing right over the when I
wasn't watching TV when I wasn't
watching you know Sanford and Son and
the Dean Martin roasts I was I was
fishing and that's just what I did so I
never got in trouble I studied I watched
TV and I did a lot of fishing so that
was a big part of me but also weird
connection is that my father whenever he
saw because all Greeks are evangelists
for being Greek you know their number
one hobby is being Greek and so my
father any time he saw a fish a chrome
fish on the back of a car on the 70s you
know he would say you see that fish that
comes from the Greek word because the
early Christians couldn't use the sign
of the Cross they had they used the
symbol of the fish because the Greek
word for fish the ancient word is egg
this that's where we get exile adjust
right and accesed the words it's an
Akron
suzka Stas they asked Eman so tear it
spells Jesus Christ the Son of God our
Savior and so they used the secret
symbol of the fish and my father says to
me in Danbury Connecticut on the highway
see that fish it's a greek word he gets
all excited about the fact that it's
Greek now I'm being a little unfair I
think he was aware of the Christian
element but he was very excited that the
fish you know is a Greek it's a Greek
word so in any event the third part of
me if you're gonna say there's fishing
there's the Greek thing the third part
of me was what I call the life of the
mind from age 16 to 24 I'm trying to
figure out the meaning of life I'm
trying to figure out Who am I why am I
here and whenever i was reading the
literature that I was reading in college
I wasn't reading it the way most people
read it I was trying to figure out what
is the clue to humanity who are we and
what and it's you know good art that's
what it does it helps you understand
what does it mean to be human and so on
and so forth so I was trying to puzzle
this out and I remember that at some
point just after graduating and getting
you know the woke memo that Christianity
is too parochial the Bible it's just a
bunch of right-wing you know right
bigots but but if there's any religion
it probably combines all religions and
it's probably more like a new-age life
force or something like that and I came
up with this idea in my own that you
know what it's sort of like Freud's idea
of the soul right where you have the
conscious mind and then you have the
unconscious below the conscious mind and
I kind of brought in a little young this
is supposed to sound pretentious I was
an undergraduate right so I have yeah I
had this idea that maybe the goal of
life is that the ice on the lake is is
the conscious mind and that the water
beneath it is the unconscious or what
Jung calls the collective unconscious
which is this God force or something
like that and I thought maybe that's
what all religions are getting at so the
goal of life is to drill through the ice
so that you have an emotionally healthy
connection between the conscious mind
and the collective unconscious or God or
whatever it is now what does that mean
practically bubkis nothing of course it
just means like I figure that out I got
it all religions say the same thing and
I'm going
move on with my life so so that's really
kind of where I was coming from which of
course led me to be really lost how do I
live what what is right what is wrong I
had no idea so I meet this guy he talks
to me about my faith and faith whatever
we we talked for about a year and at the
end of the year I had a dream my uncle
had just passed away so I was a little
bit emotionally vulnerable and beginning
to wonder is there something out there
and if there is I feel like I'm
hermetically sealed in a room with no
windows and no doors and if there's a
god out there he's gonna have to punch a
hole through the wall and say I'm here
because in the material world there's no
I have no way of logically getting there
right so in this dream I'm standing on a
frozen lake in Danbury Connecticut
Candlewood like where I fish many times
and I look down and in the hole and this
never happens if you're an ice fisherman
there's a fish kind of sticking its
snout out of the hole and I reach down
and I pick it up by the gills and it's
like a pickerel or a pike it's one of
those you know bronze golden colored
fish and I pick it up and it was it's
one of these you know in a dream like
this I'd never had a dream like this
ever in my life nor since it was like
the perfect winter day where that where
the snow and the ice are super white and
the sky is super blue and it's just
glorious and I hold up this golden fish
into the sunlight and in the dream
suddenly I know this is the golden fish
this is Ichthus this is all God sort of
one-up me with my symbol system and
these two these two paragraphs kind of
dropped into my head in the dream that
you wanted to touch inert water this God
force but I had something else for you
my son your Savior Jesus Christ it's us
and this all came together in the dream
and the weird thing is in the dream I'm
holding this fish up and I realize in
the dream it looks golden as though it's
actually made of gold and then I realize
in the dream no it is made of gold it is
a golden fish that is nonetheless alive
like out of a fairy tale and at that
moment in the dream my mind was totally
blown I
knew that God had my number that he
spoke to me in a way that made sense to
me that the thing that I had convinced
myself was impossible for intelligent
people to know you could maybe hope that
it's true that suddenly I knew it I was
stuck with it I would have to deal with
it for the rest of my life but I
couldn't go back I couldn't pretend that
God hadn't spoken to me in this
miraculous way which revealed that he
knew more about me than I knew about
myself now that is the short version of
it I apologize no no no all right well
there's a lot there so let's go so when
you have this now you have this
revelation let's say yeah
you're obviously an intellectual guy
like that seems to be where much of the
thrust of your passion is did you freak
out after that like like this was gonna
somehow erode the intellectual side of
yourself well no or turn you in the eyes
of your friends something like that well
yes that will for sure I knew that would
happen but this is where I mean look
let's say you're in the woods and you
meet Bigfoot and you know you're not an
idiot you're not on mushrooms like it
actually happened there are people that
are never gonna believe you but you're
stuck you can't convince yourself that
it didn't happen like you did it's one
of those things where when I woke up I
knew this was real I knew this was true
I knew the Bible is the Word of God I
know Jesus is aware and I knew all my
friends would think I'm nuts or Pat me
on the head and go like whatever but the
point is I didn't have a choice
I say you know what I'm just gonna
ignore this it was too powerful to
ignore it wasn't something I could walk
away from I mean it was it was God
crafting a message
literally for me in a way calculated by
the author of the universe to blow my
mind my mind was blown and but the funny
thing is Dave that I knew I remember
going to work the next day to tell my
friend this Christian who had been
talking to me and I tell him a little
bit about the dream he goes what do you
think it means and I said I've accepted
Jesus now I would have never I would
have cringed to speak those were
any time before but I said it to him
like it's done like whatever that means
that's that's what happened now you know
I didn't start voting for Republicans
the next day I would say took a time for
me to begin to process this but I knew
that I would challenge most of my
friends would be tough for them and I
the ones who were willing to hear me out
and to continue to be my friend you know
that's kind of where you realize who
your real friends are in a sense because
they were they they they accorded me
enough dignity to try to understand what
I was was telling them and the funny
thing too is that I never was like in
your face about it right but they acted
as though I was knows I remember having
lunch here in Manhattan with a
sophisticated friend and sort of saying
you know just kind of telling him this
in a very very gingerly and him sort of
exploding eye look what are you saying
everybody's going to hell about like he
just was like all over me and I just
thought that this is what this is you
know gonna be the rest of my life but
you know it's not that different from
coming out for Trump you're some people
are gonna hate you some people are gonna
think you're evil some people are gonna
look I mean the fact of the matter is
that at some point you have no choice
when that happened in the summer of 1988
I had no choice I had to do my best to
represent it as I could and and and I
you know many ways failed and in some
ways succeeded but there's just no going
back from that I wanted a miracle I got
a miracle and I've had many miracles
that have happened to me actually since
then which I I give I give the you know
they rise to the bar of calling them
miracles I'm not talking about blessings
oh that was nice you know that that is
real I've experienced it not as much as
as I would like but at this point we
could debate all kinds of stuff forever
but if somebody asks me are you sure
about the Jesus are you sure of it
there's no question I mean you can
torture me there's nothing I can do to
convince myself that I might have missed
something at this
point so speaking of miss something then
do you think that most academics like
your friend that you sat with who
brought up you know burning in hell and
the rest of it do you think that is sort
of the fundamental flaw of most
academics that then is partly why we're
watching academia crumble right now that
they've disconnected these things where
they've mocked believers to the point
that they've been left with this I'll
just mention one other thing which is I
had I had John Kasich the former
Governor of Ohio on or the guy he is the
governor of Ohio and he said something
interesting to me about this he said you
know a lot of people can do it without
God I'm just not one of those people and
I brought it up in many interviews since
then because it's not the most
enlightened thing I've ever heard it's
actually very humbling and decent yet I
found it to be really refreshingly
honest do you do you sense there's some
connection there between the way the
intellectual elite seem to be crumbling
right now there's a zero question that
the answer is yes there's no question
but look it's all related it's not just
about God I mean I'll give an example at
a place like Yale if if you are somebody
like Miroslav Wolff okay
he's a serious Christian but he's pretty
left-wing so they'll give him a pass you
know it really is but it's very
interesting what are the the different
shibboleths that people have it's like
you can say anything you want but if you
don't believe a woman should be able to
to kill what's in her womb you're a pig
and a bigot and you know it's
interesting how that how that works out
and I think that academia I mean you
know it's funny because I've written
about this you can trace this way back
to the 20s really that that it's like we
were saying earlier that there's this
trickle-down effect these ideas were
seeded Essie Edie Edie seeded into the
culture you know in in many ways from
Darwin to Nietzsche to Freud whatever it
but but they came into the culture sort
of big-time in the 20s right you know
Margaret Mead was popular having having
sex with anyone you like in Samoa you
know like this kind of vague
scientific reason for doing as we liked
became popularized but it didn't trickle
down to middle America until you get to
you know the sixties right and it still
didn't trickle down to the effect it
continues to trickle down so that now we
have arsonists and looters and potential
murderers who are pretending to care
about the death of a black man in the
way that Martin Luther King jr. Rosa
Parks Jackie Robinson would spit on them
for the desecration of the memory of
those who have suffered under real
racism I mean it you know the descent
from true American self-government and
Liberty into cultural Marxism doesn't
happen overnight but that's effectively
what we're looking at in Christianity to
me in many ways has been at the core of
this there's just no question that when
you talk about the West and it's part of
the reason for the decline of Europe I
mean when you jettison the Christianity
what what do you have exactly you know
if they were unwilling to put mention of
God in the European Parliament in their
Constitution you can't think well then
so tell me what what exactly is Europe
you know so there's no there's no
question about it and again their
degrees of this depending on on who you
talk to but there's certain things you
know this that are simply not spoken of
in certain places and faculty lounges at
places like Yale and you know the the
New York Times boardroom and and on and
on and on and on they're they're not
going to touch that stuff they have been
very happy to allow the culture to
become dramatically secular all right so
then this is gonna be a hell of a segue
watch how I do it with all of that
cultural stuff you're talking about and
the academic elites
you've written some children's book
books about Donald Trump yeah
there's I sense a connection there these
are not well coincidences I actually I
have to sort of correct you and and this
is my fault because I I have let this go
without correcting people and no I'll
tell you what I've written
dirty children's books over the years
right but I've also written a lot of
humor I was the the humor the editor of
the humor magazine at Yale I wrote a
parody of the old Ripley's Believe It or
Not books with st. Martin's Press like
20 years ago I've written a lot of humor
and when I do public speaking and stuff
there's just a lot of comedy and goofing
around on my radio program you know some
people think of me as as funny so I had
this idea when Trump was that's a good
title for a book that's a good title for
a book some people think of me as funny
I'm not gonna use it I give that to you
no no so thank you no but but the funny
but but the thing is that I like humor I
like satire I mean I'm even published
humor in The New Yorker and in the
Atlantic and stuff you know I I've loved
that kind of thing and when Trump was
elected I said to the guy my dear friend
Tim Raglan who lives in Kansas and he
and I have done a number of books
together he's a genius illustrator the
stuff we've done together is just it's
stunning but I said to him Tim you know
you're the one that convinced me to look
differently at Trump when I was still
kind of like I don't know about that guy
I'm a New Yorker and you know he's sort
of vulgar and I'm a Christian and I
don't know he's not my first pick and he
he kind of had me look at him
differently and I said Trump is like
he's like a folk hero he's like out of
one of these books that I've written
with Tim Raglan like he's larger than
life like a cartoon figure and I said
attempt him we need to do like a
children's book about a character like a
Trump character but it's really adult
satire in the form of a children's book
right now for example I wrote a lullaby
book actually for kids called it's time
to sleep my love right
some guy decided to parody that book and
use the title go the F to sleep okay now
that's sold a lot more than my book but
the point is it looks like a children's
book but it's obviously meant for adults
the thing with my book
Donald rains this one I just happen to
have a copy here Donald drains the swamp
right is that even though it's aimed at
adults because their sophisticated humor
for example the turtle
just happens to look like Mitch
McConnell that's a coincidence because
all turtles are great but but the point
is that when you're talking about the
swamp and all the senses a lot of
political humor but because there's
nothing nasty in it it works for kids so
people often say it's a kids book it's
kids but technically it's it's an adult
humor book it's a novelty book it's a
satire book and adults are gonna get all
the jokes kids aren't gonna get the
jokes they don't know who a assi is and
they don't know that bernie is a
communist and they're you know so so
we've written three of these books but
the big reason that we did them as I
said the one thing we conservatives tend
to be bad at is creating culture we talk
about politics all the time but in terms
of sitcoms or you know children's books
or the world of publishing it tends to
be taken over by the left the left
really has you know the long march to
the institutions academia publishing
journalism it's all very very leftist
and I said I want to create something
that's fun for people who actually like
this president and of course the reason
he's a caveman is sort of meant to be
funny because he is kind of a caveman
you kind of think caveman they see a
problem they fix the problem they don't
know that you're not supposed to do it
that way they just want to fix the
problem like they're good guys and they
just do it so it's not really making fun
of him but there's there's there's a
lightness to it for people who think of
him as somewhat of a caveman
but Metaxas I can see the commenters
already in the future and they're gonna
say wait a minute
how can this intellectual Christian
talking about Jesus right right support
the caveman how can it possibly be I
support him because I'm a Christian it's
it's rather simple you don't I mean look
the idea that I mean I think you you
know this right that there are people
and we see this on the Left today no
matter what you do they'll find what's
wrong with it
Trump has you know has made this so much
worse just by being Trump he's he's
driven people insane so that if he says
one plus one equals two they're gonna
say I don't know about that and
something
people say it might not in a quantum
universe that's a lot of baloney and
he's too stupid to understand what a
quantum universe is right like you can
definitely racist it's also right it's
all salts we forgot to mention those are
that saying it's racist so yeah I think
that the reason that I support Trump is
it's kind of weird actually I was
writing this humor piece for the new
yorker called more Trump Bible verses
because there was that you know contra
tomp about him not remembering something
to the bite I found the whole thing
hilarious right and so I did a whole
thing of like tweets of Bible verses
that they're kind of trumpian you know
like I don't know if I can remember any
of them right now but you know like a
good wife who can find I found three you
know whatever I you know that was just
all these Bible verses that we have some
dim memory of and then you know sort of
a trump fication of it anyway while I
was writing it for The New Yorker this
is totally true I I found myself almost
like a comedian because I have written a
lot of comedy like you're writing for a
voice you're writing for like I'm
writing for Bob Hope or I'm writing for
Jackie Mason and you kind of find that
voice and you find that rhythm and I
found myself having kind of an affection
for him in the way that you would for an
uncle that he's not you know politically
correct he he doesn't he there's a lot
of stuff about him that you know
wouldn't work among your friends but you
love him and you know he's a good man
and you know he loves his country and he
would fight and die for his country and
if you're in trouble you want him around
he's a good he's good but he's reference
and he's got a lot of things and you say
please don't say that whatever you do
please don't say that when my friends
are over they they're not going to
understand that you know and I I began
to see that side of him and then I also
realized that because I grew up in a
working-class environment he speaks to
the working-class Martin Luther about
whom I've also written had a similar
ability you know even though you know
Trump went to Wharton and is obviously
an instinctive genius there's no
question about it but he has an ability
with the working class and a big part of
that is humor and hyperbole and I began
to hear him differently and I began to
think wow the cultural elites
they don't get that language it's like
he may as well be speaking Japanese they
don't get it and so I began to
appreciate him more and more but I have
to say that if anything ever revealed to
me
how pathetic the Republican Party had
become you know when when they turned
against him the way that that he did I
mean his ability to see the problem in
China for example we'll just talk about
a minor thing really minor right 1.3
billion people I mean the the the level
of seriousness that our leaders ought to
have accorded China over the last three
decades is so huge and they basically
ignored it while it grew into a monster
Trump if he did nothing else diagnosed
the problem 30 years ago has been
talking about it for 30 years and is now
rather effectively doing a number of
things to deal with this problem how
much money is he making a lot less than
hunter Biden is making on China I don't
see him getting anything out of it
except he feels it's the right thing for
America so it's things like that that's
just one but I mean he has been very
staunchly pro-life and staunchly
religious liberty and these are things
that have concerned me deeply his his
willingness to stand up for Cavanaugh I
would bet that a lot of Republicans
people that I thought were good guys ten
years ago they would have folded at the
end and so there's there's a lot to
recommend him and you're not supposed to
vote for somebody because you think they
share your theology IIIi don't I don't
really think that's why you elect a
president it would be nice if he did but
you know it's like saying that like that
pilot is not that great but he loves
Jesus and that pilot is the best pilot
who ever flew a plane but he's had four
wives and he's been in jail you know
it's people make it sound like it's it's
a simple choice it's not a simple choice
yeah you do you live in New York City
right now
I live in Manhattan I'm here now and
yeah I live in Manhattan the reason I
ask is because to espouse those radical
views that you've just announced in
Manhattan in a strange time to live in
Manhattan I assume you have two locks on
your door well you know in all
seriousness Dave if you think about it
you know being a born-again evangelicals
and I'm not exactly a popular way to fly
around here and I've always been before
Trump I believed in the in the dignity
of the unborn I take that very seriously
I have a biblical view of sexuality you
know these are not like popular views in
blue states but the point is that this
is where I'm from I try to be respectful
of people with with whom I differ
I don't lose friendships over those
things I love people with whom I
disagree on these things and so so the
Trump thing we're just taking it to the
next level but it's kind of funny in our
building there are three couples that
love Trump to Orthodox Jewish couples
and another some kind of Gentile couple
they love Trump I mean I think there's a
lot of people in New York who who like
him or love him but they just don't say
it publicly you know I don't I don't
where Magga hat down Madison Avenue yeah
as we're going through we're taping this
a little bit before we're going to air
it so I don't want to get into like the
exact nitty-gritty of what's happening
but as we're going as we're going
through this sort of national tumult and
all of this stuff and sort of the
unraveling of the the fabric of America
that you sort of described before as
your your Greek father and your German
mother and all of this stuff and as a
guy that lives in New York City and you
just mentioned some of the people in
your building are you worried that we're
gonna look back and go man we had
something that was so freaking precious
and we didn't even realize it that
perhaps the ship has even sailed on that
already I want you to bring that up
because I've thought about this day and
night for four years now I wrote a book
I don't have a copy here but if I could
give a copy to everyone in your audience
everyone in America it's called if you
can
Franklin was asked after the
Constitutional Convention
you know dr. Frank we're gonna get to it
let's do it right now well that that's
we'll link to it will link to it yeah
but but but the fact of the matter is
that over the years because of my faith
and because of my choose me evolving
political views I began to notice some
things right and I began to notice for
example one of the reasons America is
great is that it's an idea it's not an
ethnic tribal group right everybody my
father with his Greek accent my mother
with a German accent they can become as
American as George Washington that's a
new concept in the history of the world
it's a beautiful concept and so if it's
true that America is an idea
and if we're self-governing unless
people know that idea understand how
that works and live out that idea of
governing themselves and in in a sense
teaching others how to self-govern what
this means how fragile and beautiful
this is and what we must do to keep it
if we don't it goes away absolutely
there's just no question if there's no
question whether it will go away it will
go away it's been going away so I wrote
my book if you can keep it specifically
to put in it in a small easily readable
book the very basics of what one needs
to know to get it why you need to love
your country with all its flaws why you
must love your country why you must
fight for liberty and on and on and on
and I have to say in large part because
I am a Christian I have hope when most
people wouldn't see hope I I think God's
had his hand on this country
listen Lincoln called us the almost
chosen people now why would he say that
he said it because he knew he could see
that there was something in fact he used
the phrase something uncommon this is
not just another country if you believe
that God has had his hand on the Jews
which I certainly do that's not
something you party about right it's
it's a it's a tremendous burden to be
chosen by God because it means he's
going to use you and you're going to
suffer and it's not going to be easy and
and so God has blood
this country amazingly but he's used
this country to export liberty and
wealth and on and on to the whole world
because you know just as Israel was
created by God to reach the whole world
to reach the nations outside of Israel
America and all our blessings are
intended for the rest of the world so we
have something that is so precious and
when I really understood this I wrote
the book and I I have been on a mission
because I said if we don't educate the
next generation or even this generation
it does go away and what we're seeing
right now I think is the it's the it's
the the the heat of the battle we're in
the midst of a battle where we have a
president in a sense who by God's grace
has dragged us back from the cliff of
oblivion and so we have some time you
know to back away from the cliff but if
Hillary had been elected which is you
know you asked me earlier why why how
could I vote for Trump I'm convinced
that that Hillary Clinton and Obama and
those folks are genuinely tremendously
corrupt in other words that they will
put their own interests before the
interests of the country so that's
strike three but I also believe that
their version of America their view of
America is fundamentally antithetical to
the founders view the founders view of
America they don't share they want to
undo it they have worked cleverly over
the decades to undo it along with all
the institutions I mentioned earlier and
I really believe that had Hillary been
elected for example and instead of
Robertson Cavanaugh we had gotten you
know the son of Sotomayor and bride of
Sotomayor if that had happened it's over
the Constitution just because it's a
piece of paper it's meaningless unless
we have judges that are interpreting
things according to it unless we have
people that understand it so to me
there's no question that we're we're
right on that precipice as it were yeah
so I suspect you think that even some of
the Republicans who you said before you
might have liked or at one time
supported or something like that you
think they wouldn't have been able to
stand up against this thing either right
oh they weren't standing up against it
they weren't look these are people that
I like but they were not standing up
against it that it takes tremendous
courage to stand up against what we now
call the deep state the deep state is as
tyrannical as King George the third was
it is the enemy of self-government and
liberty and when I talk about Liberty
I'm not talking about some french idea
of Liberty I'm talking about God's idea
of Liberty and how human beings are
supposed to live and and if you don't go
to war with that if you play pattycake
with that because you think well I don't
want to be the one you know the press
already hates me eventually it's going
to get worse and worse and worse and so
I really think that unfortunately I
can't you know understand how else it
could have happened but we have had
leaders who've been guilty of what
people have said to me over the years
but I never believed it that they're
they're really no different than the
other side and I thought to myself you
know that's truer than I would like to
believe when when McCain voted against
you know overturning Obamacare I thought
what a what a nightmare what a nightmare
that a man who was tortured for his
country has come to this exceedingly
peevish sick moment in his life just
before he dies that he would do
something like that that's the guy that
I voted for Mitt Romney similarly I
voted for Ed the fact that he would take
what he pretends as a principled stand
against this president I think I would
like to think that these folks are
deluded that that their their evil
actions are the result of really being
deluded because otherwise it's it's too
disturbing so we talked a little bit
about this when you interviewed me but I
thought this might be a nice way to sort
of to bring this all full circle but you
don't strike me as like a purely
political beast in that you care about
things that are sort of much bigger than
politics so it you know politics is just
a piece of it
but yet these days everything has become
so political and I'm wondering what else
do you think is important to live a full
clear life
well there's no question that my faith
on the God of the Bible is the most
important thing and that it's efuses or
at least I hope it suffuses every part
of me and takes precedence over every
part of me or every other part of me I
think that you know people who think you
can solve things through politics are
just wrong the math is wrong that it's
utopianist scheme no matter how you
slice it whether you think you can do it
through a totalitarian communist state
or you have some illusion that you can
do it in any other way I mean look I
think the founders made this clear and
this is what we've ceased to teach
Tocqueville saw it that in my in my book
if you can keep it I talked about my
friend oz Guiness came up with the term
but he calls it the Golden Triangle of
freedom and he says that freedom
requires virtue now it's an interesting
thing every single one of the founders
Ben Franklin Thomas Jefferson every
single one of them understood that
concept that self-government and Liberty
which had never been pulled off in the
history of the universe ever once was
possible if the citizenry were basically
virtuous or if there was a culture of
virtue so they all understood this they
all wrote about it and I I put most of
those quotes in my book so that you read
and you go that's wild
they all believed it there was no
argument but we're not teaching in
school so you think so so freedom
requires virtue then the founders also
believed that virtue in turn required
faith now they didn't stipulate
Christian faith nor did they dare say
faith can be enforced because they
didn't believe in that but they had seen
that virtue needs to be held up by
something what why why do I do the right
thing when no one is looking why do I
not loot when I might not get cut well
because I answer to a higher authority
they all observe this Franklin observed
this most directly and all the the
preaching of his friend George Whitfield
this evangelist you know when revival
broke out crime went down domestic abuse
went down so if government went up they
saw this happening up and down the 13
colonies and they saw that faith was
central but then the third part you know
freedom acquires virtue virtue requires
faith faith in turn requires freedom in
other words faith cannot be forced it
cannot be enforced it can be encouraged
we can teach you know we can celebrate
faith but there's nothing the government
can do to force you or me to believe
something about these transcendent
things or to act virtuously I mean maybe
you can force us to act virtuously at
the end of a gun but that's no longer
virtue so in fact they can't do that so
so the founders got this and they really
understood something that had never been
understood before and so if you think
about it there is no there's just no
escaping it once you cease teaching
respect and Zephyrs or the government
respect you no one other once cynicism
comes in the whole thing falls apart and
and so I just I I really feel I feel
hopeful but I think that it's we're in a
we're in a real battle right now there's
just there's no question about it that
every part of the what I really meant to
say was that the culture is the thing
that holds it together you can vote for
all the right people but if the culture
itself if what you see on TV if if what
is out there in the culture and in the
schools doesn't reinforce this idea
somebody I forget who called it the
habits of the heart if we're not taught
to love our country there's a part in my
book if he can keep it I remember in
fifth grade an old teacher her last year
let us outside on June 14th was one of
the last days of school to celebrate
Flag Day and it was this sacred moment
and she never said it but she was
teaching us to love our country to
respect the flag in the most in the most
sweet way we've really ceased doing that
mostly and I think when you cease doing
that politics will fail you cultures
upstream of politics and in conservative
conservatives and Christians have
notoriously abdicated the world of
culture as important as politics is and
you know it is and I know it is we can
advocate culture which is why do you
silly things like right Donald the
caveman books and you know have a have a
talk show where I talk to novelists and
and so on and so forth because I
actually think that is the part of the
battle where we have failed most
miserably Metaxas I will keep fighting
alongside of you what do you think of
that I'm so happy to finally get to know
you and it really you're an
encouragement to me and to many people
so thank you for what you do and thanks
for giving me an opportunity to rant and
rave I just needed to get those things
off my chest
likewise my pleasure and we're gonna
link down to all the books and what wait
what's your Twitter I'm not remembering
it off the top of my hair I just attack
America taxes Facebook Twitter Instagram
Eric Metaxas and you tell my friend
thank you so much thank you
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlists
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell